ah yes
saw that I saw the new Hellraiser which
is like uh
I saw the new hell rate dude I [ __ ]
did it you know me and my OCD dude me
and my [ __ ] obsessive [ __ ] I watched
the new Hellraiser and then what did I
do if you know me and you're a real fan
what did I do dude if this is a
crystallia game show I saw the new
Hellraiser and then what did crystalia
do a
start watching all of them from the
beginning or B went to bed
if you guys stay yay dude I started
watching the first one and I just go man
it's like because I watched the [ __ ]
end the new one on Hulu okay I've never
seen a Hellraiser before
and uh well I used to love that Tupac
song Mama Rosa he'll raise up
so I've watched the Hellraisers uh new
one and I'm like okay all right
all right okay so these guys can't tell
the difference between Pleasure and Pain
okay
and he thought he wanted to [ __ ] he
thought he wanted to you know he thought
he wanted to have
what happens is when you [ __ ] move
the block around in the right direction
you get to pick what you want to be your
Ultimate Fantasy and you can be Pat it
could be power love Resurrection or
sensation or two other ones it's there's
six choices I don't know and they call
them like Leviathan [ __ ] Leviticus
and all the shits I don't know what it
is but
begin with Alan
the guy picked Sensations and yeah
[ __ ] like a clock went in the middle
of his chest and it started making him
feel Sensations and he didn't realize
that to these cenobites who are [ __ ]
Jesus I sound like a [ __ ] dork what
he didn't realize is to the cenobites
okay okay uh Pleasure and Pain is
actually the same thing and sensation
you know they can't tell the difference
between Pleasure and Pain so it just
makes me laugh so the guy thought he was
gonna have like complete orgasms but
just makes him laugh because instead you
know they just put a bunch of strings
and um
and like [ __ ] this contraption in his
chest and they would pull on it and make
him feel pain every few minutes and this
makes me laugh he thought he's going to
be [ __ ] absolutely busting
um so
ah
anyway I watched it and I was like okay
okay okay
all right
I'll watch the [ __ ] for okay it ended
and I go like this fine dude I'll watch
the original
oh what okay you got me dude
s m Blood and Guts and Gore
all right you win Universe I'll stay
seated and go all the way to the
beginning
so I turned on the original Hellraiser
all right now before I did that what did
he do Diddy a
make popcorn or B
Google the ins and outs of every
Hellraiser movie and also uh find out
which Hellraiser movies were the best
and people explaining the movie
Hellraiser in depth and reading a bunch
of different articles about that if you
guess me yeah
Chris doesn't make popcorn because it
takes time and he wants to eat stuff
immediately so he eats stuff like
pretzels and ice cream that's already
pre-made
yay dude
when he's really hungry he gets [ __ ]
pissed off because he has to make a
sandwich yay dude he'd rather just
[ __ ] eat something that's pre-made
yay B the answer is B worst cake Joe of
all time so
you
God
Crest and so
um
wow imagine if you had it I should have
that game show so anyway the answer was
B and so [ __ ]
on our show today the answer went a and
then B and then so I read everything and
then I watched it I was like all right
all right you really wet my appetite
articles
you really wet Miami really you're
really wet my fangoria appetite articles
so
um
so I did it so I watched the [ __ ] I
started watching the beginning I watched
25 minutes
his eyelid's got heavy
so what did he do dude how well do you
know crystallia did he a go directly to
bed or B watch another thing that wasn't
so [ __ ] demonic so he could clear it
and then get into a better mood and then
go to bed
if you guess me you get it you
God
Crest worst game show so
so I did I turned on a little thing and
I went to bed and I woke up and I
[ __ ] finished it dude now finishing a
movie like Hellraiser in the morning
[ __ ] up your day nice to meet you day
okay we're [ __ ] up good catch you
later crazy
[Music]
crazy congratulations
[Music]